the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the balicar
rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm chris hogan and
hosting along with me
this hour is ramsey personality mr
anthony o'neil and we are
excited to be with you we need to light
up these phone lines
i know you're out there i know you've
got some money questions i know you've
got some things on your mind that you'd
like to talk about and we're here for
you
so ao are you ready man i'm ready man
you properly caffeinated
yes sir well you know caffeinated for me
it's just waking up you know i'm just a
young energetic guy
okay you're not that young all right uh
we're excited to take your call
get on the phone and pick it up people
call us 888-825-5225
again that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
kelly's standing by she's ready to jump
on the phone to take your call
also find us on social media we'd love
to be able to hear from you
all right ayo let's get on the line uh
we've got uh looks like we've got
william on the line william how are you
i'm doing chris how are you i'm focused
and not finished my friend how can we
help you today
yeah so i've been uh doing dave's plan
well started dave's plan uh the
beginning of last year during the
pandemic i found him online
and i'm having trouble getting my wife
on track with starting the baby steps
and being gazelle intense like you guys
say
and i just wanted to see what you guys
would think would be the best way to get
her
you know motivated to be debt-free well
what's her issue what's the problem
well i don't know i think she's not she
she knows about dave dave's plan but
maybe
she's just not feeling like it's doable
to pay off the debt that we have
okay well hold on william let's back up
a second so
talk to us like we're your wife what did
you come home and say
hey we're your wife come tell us what
you said how did you go home and
introduce this to your wife
well she knew who dave was because her
mother tell me what you tell her
i told her that i wanted to do the plan
that i read the total
money makeover i wanted to do start the
baby steps okay
why did you want to start the baby steps
because we make too much money to be
broke okay
that's what i told her that was my exact
word that we're really blessed with the
incomes that we're able to
bring in okay and we should be good
stewards of our money
all right william how many kids do you
all have kids
yeah we got two uh ones two and one
seven
how much money do you make a year
william
last year 2020 we made 140 000. okay
oh okay all right now let's get to the
nitty-gritty they will come back to this
wife situation
what kind of debt do you have um
well we have her student loans
which are 58 000 i have a 401k loan
that's uh
70 uh 7 800. what kind of loan did you
say that was
401k a 401k loan i took it out to buy a
car after release
okay that's all right what else you got
uh then we have our mortgage that is a
hundred and
seventy thousand okay all right ao where
are you going
what are you gonna tell me i don't know
if you wanna come to me first everybody
come on
uh i'm a little different man i'm ready
for it now
because i don't even know i don't even
know my answer is the right answer
because i've never been married
uh you know but i'm in a safe place i
said it's a respectful way i think
now i'm not even gonna play with you
like that here's the thing man i think
one of the reasons why ladies
uh or why and i'm not married so i'm
trying to be careful what i say hogan
right i understand
um see i'm a little different i'll say
hey this is what we're gonna do and
here's why we're going to do this i
think sometimes men we have to step up
and lead with love
lead with compassion um but i don't i
think you say bae
we're going to do this because i want us
to be financially well i want to start
building legacy i want to start building
wealth i need to trust me on this
that's how i would have started the
conversation not just by saying
it but also by saying it followed by the
explanation
and just taking the lead yeah william i
i think it's one of these things where
it's not talking at her it's talking
with her see that's a problem and
what i would do is sit down and really
talk about because i'm going to tell you
right now
i know the number one thing that you all
are united in
i know the number one motivator for both
of you or common ground that you all can
lock horns and get serious about this
and it's those two kids you see you
talking to her about the legacy and the
mindset and the things you want your
kids to have
because i don't know a parent or a
grandparent on this planet that don't
want their kids or grandkids to have
better
than what they had and the only way
william for your kids to have better as
if
you all do better so i would sit down
and talk with her
you're talking at her right now and
that's that's that's a good start
but if you want to get on the same page
ask her about her dreams
ask her about her hopes and desires and
what she wants to accomplish
how does she envision the future for the
kids how does she envision the future
for you all
and uniting in that dream will get you
all talking and
communicating and then you can start to
say you know honey i've seen this plan
or i've seen this bald man dave ramsey
there's another bald man but he's nicer
that's for me that's me
that's me but they've got a plan that's
helped millions of people
and i want us to start helping ourselves
no let me ask you is there hogan am i
wrong
and i it's maybe why i'm still single
well i would have told my wife what
we're doing
okay well no i mean i'm just saying
we're gonna get our money right
we're gonna get our money right yeah
this is what we're gonna do yeah
this is what i think we should do now
this is what we're going to do this is
what i think we should do
yeah see okay boy we got to help this
young man over here
he knows better now he's just harassing
he's messing up but but i'm going to
tell you this ao for real
when we start talking about the things
we have in common yes
and the dreams that we have in common
now you can start to move in a direction
it's all about unity it is about unity
man
and so if you're out there and your
spouse isn't on board
what you have to do is begin to talk and
find out why i don't know why we're
hesitant to ask questions
why aren't you willing to try or what is
it that you're scared of
most people in getting serious about
money whenever you start talking about
working a plan
people automatically start to think of
what they can't do
they see it as handcuffs yes and it's
really not it's really a matter of a
budget gives you permission to spend
now you're going to spend without guilt
or without having drama
and so now you start to get united so
sit down with her and have a
conversation yeah and i think too when
you're having a conversation hogan ask
yourselves each other why
and i always say if your why doesn't
make you cry then the price of
commitment will make you cry
and figure out what is that deep why you
said your the two kids could be their
common ground
well get down to the y like why do you
want what you want for your kids
and when you start getting emotional on
the inside man
those two coming together will go after
it even harder and even better
she'll actually start taking the lead
more than him he'll be like yes this is
the wife that i've been wanting
yesterday that's right uh so i mean i
i totally agree joking earlier uh just
for radio but honestly i think if the
both of them can come together
i'm being real nope you were being bossy
my future wife may be listening right
now oh she's listening to think that ah
she's listening and she's gonna call me
at the break
but here's the thing william you guys
make a hundred forty thousand dollars
you've got fifty eight thousand dollars
in student loans
7 800 and a 401k and 170 000 in your
mortgage
if you all will lock arms and get
serious and she's probably also feeling
a little
little regret about this student loan
debt she's feeling a little regret
having such a large amount of debt
standing in the way but i love your
pronouns brother
i love you you said we have yeah she has
this but we are this
and that kind of mindset you guys can
knock this out
if you get serious yeah if you lock arms
and get intentional
this is a 18 to 24 month thing and i'm
talking about all the student loan debt
gone
so get connected with her sit down hold
her hand
talk with her not at her and watch what
happens when you all get united y'all
gonna start moving some stuff brother
you can do this and we're here to help
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org backslash
[Music]
budget
[Music]
welcome back everyone this is the ramsay
show i'm chris hogan and hosting along
with me this hour is anthony o'neil
and we're taking your calls about your
life and your money
uh we got we got some folks in the lobby
uh just want to remind you that if
you're ever in the area
uh come by the office and uh you can
check it out miss melissa over there
will
have coffee and cookies and stuff for
you but we got folks in from colorado
there's a little gang here hanging out
idaho california's in the house i mean
this is amazing uh
so come on check us out we'd love for
you to see the new building love of an
opportunity to be able to meet you
uh up on the ramsay show stage all right
we're going back to the phones
uh remember if you're out there and
you've got a question pick that phone up
and call us
uh the number to call is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
again that's eight eight eight eight two
five five two two five
we would love to be able to talk to you
and find out what's on your mind
all right we're going back to the lines
uh phone lines we got mercedes
uh calling us mercedes how are you i'm
good thank you
chris ah focus to not finish how can we
help you today
um hi anthony as well um just a question
to clarify about baby step number four
um i know it's 15 of gross income
my husband and i have a household income
where
marginal tax rate is 53.5
does that still apply 15 growth
or would you do something different in
that case okay well now the fifteen
percent is still going to stay the same
uh what's you all's household income
um net after tax sure up
about 700. okay all right and
let me ask you do you all have any debt
right now
yeah okay so your home is paid for and
everything
uh the home is not paid for no we do
have a mortgage okay well that'd be debt
so what how much do you owe on the home
yes
uh 1.5 okay all right
so uh what what line of work are you all
in
um my husband is an investment advisor
okay
all right and so looking at this yeah
the income side
uh welcome to texas uh but but
you guys are in canada i'm correct right
yes okay so even in looking at that yeah
you're going to get in that habit of the
15
of their household income from an
investing standpoint
uh your husband being an investment
advisor he knows you know there are
options and things that you guys can do
obviously pre-tax but post-tax
uh you guys have a little bit different
investment system up there with rrsps
but you still have the opportunity to be
able to save and invest
but also you guys would look at
opportunities to really throw
i mean get hyper vigilant and gazelle
intense
at chopping down that mortgage yes
and that's what we've been doing like
we're paying it unfortunately i found
you guys
after we bought the place so we're not
on a 15.
but we're paying it as though it is at
15. okay well and mercedes you know how
often people continue to do that
consistently rarely okay
no i'm serious everybody's got
intentions but i thought i heard
something over there you guys have kids
i just want you yeah how old is the baby
uh almost a year and a half okay see i
knew i heard that sound i got that
paternal instinct
uh but you guys be in focus i would i
would tell you i advise you i'd go
refinance to a 15-year fix
uh you guys have the income you can do
it uh
you're gonna see it then and it's going
to be five six seven hundred dollars
more
but just getting in that habit
refinancing it down to a 15 is going to
lock you into that
so now it's not a matter of if you feel
like it or not
uh you guys are going to have to avoid
what's called income stupid
meaning because you do have a higher
level of income you can tend to do
stupid on a larger scale
can i get an amino amen brother and so
you got to be careful with that
uh so you guys locking in on a 15 being
intentional and also ao with that little
one they can start saving for college
absolutely man i would definitely start
looking at 529 if they're already not
doing it because it sounds like they're
they're doing the right things
you know they're asking the right
questions so i would definitely open up
a 529
and start stacking away some money for
college yeah they're in canada so you'd
have to look and see what's the
equivalent up there of you all being
able to put money away
but then at the same time being
intentional and i mean attacking this
mortgage
at your income level this house can be
paid off in two to three years tops
without you all sacrificing lifestyle
mercedes so sit down talk to your
husband
uh he'll either see that picture or he
may be too wise to see it right now
because a lot of people ao try to
convince themselves because there are
people out there that don't know how to
count
that having a mortgage is a good thing
so you can write off the interest you've
got to be kidding me
you know i people when i hear nerds say
that i want to grab them by their pocket
protector and just shake them
but i can't do that because that's
assault but i want people to understand
you know you pay it off you remove the
risk of the mortgage in your life
you're getting rid of risk you're
freeing it up and now you can donate
money to charities or causes you believe
in
and use that as the tax right off man
you teaching good today you okay hogan
i'm i'm fired up today what's in this
drink leave it alone there's caffeine in
there baby
i'm rolling all right people listen to
me if you're out there you got a
question pick that phone up
uh pick it up pick it up call us triple
eight eight two five five two two five
again that's 888-825-5225 or find us on
social media
you can find anthony at anthony o'neil
you can find me
at chris hogan360 or the ramsey show
uh as well so you've got ways you can
reach out and we'd love to hear from you
all right let's talk somebody else we're
gonna keep it rolling
john from tennessee how are you
uh somewhat focused but not finished all
right
i'll take that what's on your mind i i
need a little uh
focus help all right so i landed a new
job last year
and moved from washington state to
god loving country of tennessee okay and
um the company threw in a lot of
benefits for this move where they helped
sell the house in washington helped me
buy the house here
okay uh with my income level as well and
all these benefits
uh my combined income
ended up putting this up about a quarter
of a mil for the year
surprise surprise we were contributing
to a roth
the whole time okay so my investment
professional said we had to
pull those funds out of the roth and
send it back to you because we can't
make those contributions because i made
too much money apparently last year to
do the law
well now the question is is since they
pulled all those funds and send them
back to me um
where do we put it well here's the thing
you could have done
all they had to do was utilize it and
and do what's called a backdoor roth
yeah where you open up the traditional
yeah go ahead and pay the taxes on it
right
converting it back over uh so i already
have
a uh ira that's open i already have a
traditional one right absolutely so but
you have
go ahead the way he explained it to me
was um
we would have to uh figure out exactly
the percentages and everything else to
be able to roll it out of
the traditional right to put it into the
back door roth
and uh it got to the point where we're
like we're really confused on
how do we do that if i already have an
existing um ira
okay so it's two separate things my
friend uh you need to reach out with the
smartvestor pro
uh go over to daveramsey.com uh and
we're gonna get you with connected with
a smart investor pro
your traditional ira that you already
had open
that's fine that one is there what i'm
saying is is the money you were putting
in
for the roth that they're now saying
income level you can't do
you can do a back door roth which means
you're opening up another traditional
ira
and go ahead and paying the taxes on it
which converts it to a roth
so you you guys you still have options
buddy uh
we got to get you with someone that can
walk you through this and show you
uh the the process higher income earners
uh
you know if you're making over 150 000
or over 200 000 if you're married
you still have opportunities to use
investment tools
uh and it's so important to get with the
right people john so thank you for
calling in
uh go over to dave ramsey.com we're
gonna get you connected with one of our
smart vester pros
uh that'll be able to walk you and guide
you through this uh
you know the the crazy thing is is as
your income increases so
does the government's hand in your
wallet uh it's called
taxes i'm still searching for fica to
this day
i don't i don't like them i don't like
them but but we got to deal with it and
we got to be on the ball and make sure
things are ready
and speaking of this uh it's time for
taxes my friends
we got to get these things situated uh
and i know you've got a lot of irons in
the fire you've got a lot of life
happening
but what you don't want to do is put
this off so if your taxes
aren't complicated you can file online
we've got a thing called ramsey smart
tax
so do me a favor text the word tax to
33789
again text the word tax to 33789
and you can get started on your taxes
today let's go on to get that out of
your way so you can sleep easy
and let your hair down this is the
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
chris hogan and hosting along with me
this hour is anthony o'neil
and ao is out there all over the place
on social media if you've not found him
on youtube you need to check him out at
anthony o'neil
uh he's on youtube instagram facebook
twitter all the things
uh but he's got a a a show and
it's called the table with anthony
o'neil and it's now available as a
podcast
so you can subscribe to wherever you
listen to podcasts
uh but with every new episode and again
on mondays
he's gonna talk about how to set a clear
vision for your future so you can start
winning in your life your money
and your relationships and he's going to
give you everything you need to know to
be successful in what it takes for you
to make your dreams
a reality now ao i i love those two
things love what you're doing with the
show there
it's point number three where we got to
have a discussion
uh this this is the third thing that
ao's doing on the show how you can go
from looking fake rich
to becoming real wealthy oh yeah um
are you are you going over into the
wealth lane
yeah okay well that lane is is taken
that lane is it's busy already my friend
hey well brother you know what i'm
saying i mean
do your thing brother cause you know
that's what i thought we were on the
same page hey man listen man
just when i thought we were a team it's
all good that's we are a team man that's
fine
you talking to older people i'm talking
to younger people
no seriously it is one of those where
you know if you've not seen ao
uh on video or on stage you need to uh
he's high energy
uh very focused very effective in his
communication uh excited for the show
uh you need to check it out it is the
table with anthony o'neil
again you can find that on youtube and
look it up but check it out
and also if you're out there and you've
got cousins nieces or nephews
uh that are millennials and you're going
boy i wish i would have known this stuff
earlier
you've got a great opportunity as an
uncle an aunt or a parent
uh to send the young people toward this
young man
uh to give opportunity to connect and
we've got a great opportunity to impact
the youth
of this country we just have to we have
to do something we do man and i think
sometimes i'm really
and the reason why i'm going this path
hogan is because
i remember when i was young i remember
when i was in my young 20s i didn't have
someone in their 30s 10 years older than
me
who was just having a real relevant and
a relatable conversation
that made me want to be debt-free that
made me want to look at life differently
because
everyone who was older than me made me
being dead free look kind of boring you
know
look look kind of old and so i was like
you know what being debt free can be
sexy it could be cool
it could be popular but you got to have
a cool young person in space and so
that's why i said hey
this i believe god has called me here to
to really have that real relatable and
relevant conversation
and i keep it 100 about my struggles
even today sometimes i'm like yo i
i don't want to wait but then i gotta i
have to talk myself into waiting
and go back to my deep why so the
conversation is not for everyone but
it's definitely for
uh young people i would definitely say
in between 18 and about 39 years old
who really want to start taking control
of their finances but you've been on my
show
um and once they get through with me i'm
always pushing them to you i'm pushing
them to rachel i'm pushing the can to
get a career
we are a team yeah i'm just trying to
bring in that young adult oh i know it
man
uh and it's it's helpful and you know we
can start having these conversations
with young people and start to plant
those seeds yeah you never know what you
can help them to avoid
absolutely uh watch this all y'all in
the lobby raise your hand if you've done
something stupid with money
okay see we got real people out there
people yeah you didn't put your hand up
bail
you need to put hands i'm 99 okay that's
true don't don't get technical with me
okay i'm bigger than you don't get
technical with me on this radio show
hey but listen people we are a team uh
here at ramsey solutions we are very
focused on helping people in all phases
of their lives
have hope and it's really important if
you've not engaged with
ramseysolutions.com get over to the
website
take a look at all the things that are
going on real quick before i get back to
the phone lines i also need to let you
know
we are hiring yeah okay we are hiring we
are always looking for top-notch
quality individuals i'm looking at one
of the gentlemen out there we were
talking at the break
i told him i said you better come on
you're gonna apply so if you're out
there and you go
boy i'd love to work in a place where
i'm valued
where they want my opinion they want my
input and they're gonna let me work
they're gonna let me do my job
uh you've got a great opportunity uh by
going over to ramseysolutions.com
uh to do work that matters and that's
one of the mantras we have here
and it's one of the things we say and if
you've ever wished that you could wake
up on sunday
happy about going to work on monday this
is a place you need to check out
uh you can do it you can find all the
information and especially
if you are uh uh in the digital space
again we're on the hunt for many
software engineers right now with
expertise and
i'm about to tell you a whole lot of
things that i've heard of and have no
idea about
so bear with me if you've got expertise
in ruby on rails
java oh i've heard of that one c-sharp
and front-end technologies we want you
or if you're a ux designer seo or
content marketing specialist
we'd love to talk to you as well uh go
over to ramseysolutions.com you can see
all of the openings
we are having people relocate coming in
and loving it
but you have a lot of areas that you can
see they've got it up right now if
you're watching on youtube you can see
there are probably about
12 areas that we're looking we have open
active open positions in so definitely
check that out and make this the year
that you start to move in the direction
of your dream career or your dream job
uh and it may not be here maybe you're
wanting to find that somewhere else
and i'd also want to encourage you to
listen to my friend ken coleman
one of our colleagues here who's helping
people find that dream job
and let's start life is too short uh ken
is helping you fig find your career
you can go to kencoleman.com and learn
more about his show
life is too precious to waste let's move
forward in the right way that's right
let's get on the phone lines uh we've
got danielle on the line danielle what's
your question for anthony
hey anthony this is uh danielle i'm uh
29 years old my husband is
or sorry i'm 30 my cousin's 29 i
apologize for that
we just completed baby step number two
okay congratulations i'm just trying to
figure out um i'm the spender and i'm
always like
wanting to find the next best thing
which is kind of bad but i've gotten a
little bit better with it that's great
and i used my why as the reason to help
pay off my debt
yeah yeah yeah it was mostly just like
student loans and whatnot love it how do
you get the motivation to keep going
like we've paid off our debt we're
getting ready to go
davis member number three and i'm just
like i'm
seeing what we want and i want to just
go for it yeah yeah and i'm trying to
keep myself to slow down
no i'm with you daniel i'm the spender
too you know i really am
and so you know uh i want to relate with
you on that part hogan
you're not on this call so don't worry
about this uh so i want you to know 101.
i'm with you
okay i when i see something i want it
now and i want the very
best of it and so uh i'm with you in
that part
but then your why still needs to carry
on
through all throughout all baby steps
and so if your why is not as
passionate to get you through baby set
number three then that means your why
hasn't you haven't gone deep enough for
your why
okay so any very quickly what's your why
in 10 seconds what's your why it
honestly to change my family trading
okay cool here now follow this
why do you want to change your family
tree
i was tired of being broke my whole life
and i don't want to be like that when i
grow up
got you why do you why are you tired of
being broke your whole life
couldn't do anything couldn't go on
trips couldn't just go and get something
to eat with my kids okay why do you want
to go on trips with your kids
i was never able to do that when i was
younger i always got told no
you see what i'm saying so your why is
you don't want to tell your kids
no your why is like me i grew up with
with tennis shoes that had holes in it
and i had to put tapes on the bottom of
my uh tennis shoes
to prevent water from getting in it and
i never want my child to go through that
my why is so deep that if i start really
breaking down my why
i'm gonna break down in here with two
grown good old chocolate brothers and i
don't want to do that right now okay and
so for you i'm saying you got to go
deeper
deeper deeper deeper i asked you four
whys
you and your husband need to go down
deeper so this way you can get your
three months
you just paid off how much debt it was
forty seven thousand eight hundred fifty
two
wow so you just paid off all of that
debt that's not easy
that that required intentionality it
required determination and you did it
so now what you're doing is okay these
three to six months
is gonna help me not help me but help my
husband and i to not go back there but
it also will set us up
to where we can start giving our kids
wealth we can start giving our kids
kids freedom we can start giving our
kids um joy
you know i really want you to spend time
tonight danielle
do this for me tonight it's the weekend
you and your husband sit down
and just keep asking yourself why when
you answer a question why do that
question
and get emotional you get that you will
get your three months knocked out
uh in your emergency fund within the
next three to six months
all right when we come back from break
i'm going to talk to you about one of
the biggest lessons we should have
learned in 2020.
you want to know what it is stay tuned
we'll be right back this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
chris hogan and hosting along with me
this hour is anthony o'neil and i tell
you we've had some
some some spicy conversations already
and i absolutely love it
got people calling in asking real
questions about their life and their
money
now before we went to break i told you
when we come back
i'm going to talk with you about
something that is you really should have
learned in 2020
and anthony was just talking to a caller
about this
and i'm talking about an emergency fund
if you didn't understand the
importance and the value of an emergency
fund last year
you learned it right you learned it
understanding having that money set
aside to protect you and your family
from life happening because life is
gonna happen and so having that cushion
well you know ao i think about you know
what an emergency fund is it's a
it's a bodyguard oh yeah it's a
lifeguard it's a big boy
it is just sitting there ready to
protect you so i want you to get serious
about making sure you have that
the problem with us is in america today
is we can get amnesia
we can live through something and say i
ain't gonna forget this but guess
what'll happen
you blink your eyes five or six times
and we tend to forget
so get an emergency fund for you and
your family and place asap
we talk about having three to six months
of an emergency fund
and ao people say well why do you say
that three two six
well i want you to know if you're
working a stable job
and you've got a stable income then a
three-month emergency fund is suffice
for you yeah but if you are someone
who's commissioned
uh you're seasonal yeah then you
definitely want to look to have more of
a six-month emergency fund
and so what that'll do is again provide
cushion between you
and life happening so it's important get
your emergency fund i'm hearing from a
lot of people ao
that they've learned that the hard way
and they're getting it in place
absolutely
i'm telling right now man i love it last
year when some things happened like for
an example okay i just got in the car
accident
yeah and uh when i walked away from it i
was shook that morning but when i woke
up the next morning called the insurance
company
and found out the car was total i wasn't
i was upset
but i wasn't like oh what am i going to
do because i have my emergency fund
right in place for situations like this
that's right
you know and so it just when you have
that emergency fund not only is it a
bodyguard but it's also just
some cushion to your life you know you
fall back on it you're like all right
cool so it's
it's an inconvenience but i'm not
stressed i'm not struggling
i am upset but i mean hey at least i can
move forward well and the main thing is
you're all right
and and but you're right having that
emergency fund it changes the game
so again get it situated and if you're
out there and you go all right hogan
you're talking about this emergency fund
thing
what do i do well i wanna i wanna i want
you to know you can get plugged into
ramsey plus
uh which will help guide you on the
process of not understanding just how to
budget
yeah but also the threat of debt but
it's gonna show you the importance and
how to go about that emergency fund
and so you can do this all you have to
do is go over to ramseysolutions.com or
go to ramseyplus.com
that's what you do it's quicker
ramsayplus.com
go on over there right now get in your
free trial and watch what happens
you're going to start to change your
financial life all right enough of that
got to get on the phone i got
ann on the line and how are you
hi chris hi anthony thank you for taking
my call yes ma'am how can we help you
today
um i'm finding myself you know
not disciplining myself enough to try to
pay off my
home my home okay i'm on a fixed
income a disability retirement income
and um i'm only the only debt that i
have
is my mortgage and but i'm kind of
stingy with
letting extra money go so i'm just
trying to
get some guidance on how i can do that
okay well hold on a minute uh what what
what do you mean you're kind of stingy
what do you mean
well i i know i have enough to
send you know to extra to pay on my
mortgage
what if something happened right so and
you know you know what your answer is
i just said why don't you send in extra
on the mortgage the straight up answer
is
because you don't want to mm-hmm
am i telling the truth yeah i'm not sure
right
and so what we got to do ao was just
talking about
digging in and finding the why
so why why should you pay extra on the
mortgage
because i want to get this paid off and
why do you want it paid off
to me i get to be debt free why you want
to be that free
i don't have to really worry about worry
about a lot of things that's right there
you go
you see and so looking at this now what
you can do is be real with yourself
and now you can start to figure out okay
what's the plan now yeah
so tell me this how much income do you
have coming in
each month um
about 35 70. okay and how much is your
mortgage payment
uh 11 30. and how much do you owe on the
house
about 155. and listen to me anne
because i tend to talk fast what else do
you owe on
nothing okay now people get amnesia on
me and sometimes so let me just double
check
you gotta eat credit cards i have one
how much is on it all the only thing i
owe is eight dollars on it
it is that's because it's a it's it's
one of those ones where they have a
maintenance fee every month
with eight dollars okay so we're going
to close that out and get rid of that
all right got any car loans
no all right now what i'm saying is
looking at it do you have an emergency
fund in place
um i'm gonna have savings how much do
you have
in savings about 12 000.
okay so you got an emergency fund we got
to see
for you you need the structure yeah
did you do this alone all right and
listen to me my i got one here on top of
this head
tell me this do you have a 15-year
mortgage or did you do a 30-year
30. it's a 30-year all right what's your
interest rate on this mortgage
okay so it's a conventional so actually
the law it
allowed me to finance the 20 percent and
so the 20 percent is 4.75 and the 80
uh part is 2.24
you did an 80 20. they gave you a heloc
didn't they
a home equity line of credit is what
that was
i don't i don't know if it's a huge yeah
it is it is i'm not sure oh yeah
it is and so they gave you a big old
credit card attached to your house is
what that is
oh okay so okay all right here's the
reality
for you you are sitting at a point you
got 3 570
coming in a month you've got an
incredible opportunity to really zero in
and get focused yeah
and i say that because you know the
eighty percent loans at two point
i think you said two point two nine but
if you zero in and get intentional
quote pay that little eight dollars on
that little dirty credit card off today
okay the little maintenance charge shut
it down shut it down get it out of your
life
but turn your attention over to this 20
now and get this thing serious and get
it paid off
uh you can do this is anybody else in
your family ann
ever owned their home free and clear
i know everyone's just financed did you
hear that
yes you want you want you want to do
something new for your family tree
yeah you really you would you would you
love to hold them grand babies on your
lap one day and talk to them about how
you paid off that house
how that deed is over there in a frame
and you can go over and grab it
so yeah yeah and and i think hopefully
you heard hogan earlier you know when
i'm listening to you
i don't really feel the depth
in your motivation
and i really want you to spend this
weekend really just asking yourself
what's my why
it sounds like you you want to be safe
and i totally understand it
i don't need to know your age but by the
way you're sounding it sounds like you
would rather be safe
than be aggressive but i think that's
okay but at the same time if you're
making that kind of money
and you can be a little bit more
aggressive and still be safe
and go ahead and create uh some wealth
for your family so what i
really pray that you you do from this
phone call is hear hogan hear
hear me um spend this weekend just
digging in why
why why why do i want financial freedom
why do i want financial peace
and when you get that deep enough why
your motivation
is going to be so good to i think you
may even start leaning more on the
aggressive side
than safe side yeah ao's being nice i'm
being coach hogan
and get fired up let's get intentional
and start changing your family tree
be that story that your great grandkids
get to talk about because you got
focused and not finished young lady
you can do this and we're here to help
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money i'm chris hogan
and hosting along with me this hour is
anthony o'neil
and we are excited to talk to you about
your money questions
so here's the deal i want you to pick up
the phone but call us
triple eight eight two five five two two
five again that's 888-825-5225 we'd love
to be able to hear from you
kelly is standing by ready to take your
call you can also find us on social
media
at ramsey show or at anthony o'neil or
at chrishogan360
we'd love to hear your questions and be
able to talk to you about what's on your
mind
uh ao are you ready to help the people
man let's do it man i'm ready to go to
the phones all right let's do it we're
going to get to the phone we got
michelle
michelle's on the line calling from
denver colorado michelle how can anthony
and i
help you hi chris and anthony and
company
i appreciate your time and i'm so
grateful to speak with you well thank
you
thank you what's on your mind i am 49
self-employed single and i have zero
debt um
and i want to know what the best method
to pay for our first home is
okay i love it talk to us
you're self-employed so how much money
are you making a year
um approximately 40 40 000
okay you're making 40k a year all right
and do you have any other income as far
as outside of your your business coming
in
no i don't i do have approximately
600 000 assets saved how much
600 000 600k now wait a minute i like
this where did this money come from was
inherited
did you just save it no this is saving
oh i love it investing lots of investing
uh michelle how much of the 600 is
invested for retirement
so approximately 200.
okay and so the other 400 is just in a
savings account
no it's divided um with stocks mutual
funds
oh okay okay got you so real quick 200
of it is in a 401k you said
how much of it is in single stocks well
it can't be in the form
um it's yeah it's not an affordable 1k
it's um it's in a retirement fund yeah
oh retirement fund okay i thought it was
a prior 401k
how much is in single stocks um
not too much quite a bit in mutual funds
okay okay go ahead i have approximately
um about 180 in
between an offshore account and um
another yeah 180 offshore account so
okay very good i like it like so let me
ask you this question because you're
you're in a good position i kind of like
the fact that you have some money
i'm gonna let hogan talk about that
because i would really love to get your
retirement
uh package and portfolio up a little bit
more but what's your dream
situation do you want to pay cash for a
home um or
are you okay with financing at a fixed
rate with 20
down i would be completely happy to get
a mortgage but i can't get a mortgage at
the moment
because of the pandemic qualifying
during the pandemic which is
very difficult yeah especially with the
forty forty thousand dollars a year of
income um now what do you do i'm curious
um i'm a mariner i work
on uh sell selling yachts yup yup
selling them but selling them okay okay
okay
because i would definitely say the very
first thing is i'm thinking is and
correct me from ron hogan
um i want to see your retirement go up a
little bit more
and so i don't want to pull 400 000 from
your investments i actually
would prefer for you to move some of
that over to into your retirement so
it's covered for retirement
but i don't have a problem with you
pulling some of it out because i have
some money in a in a mutual fund as well
that i'm saving up for before i purchase
a home so when i'm ready to purchase
my dream home i'm a pull from that uh
but you're right it's gonna be hard for
her to get approved for a mortgage right
now at 40k with the pandemic
um and then to pay cash for a home in a
denver area
you're going to need about two to two to
280 to get a decent hole
um so what are you thinking hogan
michelle is this 40 000
is this the most you've made or was your
income higher before
my my income was higher i was working
overseas for approximately 10 years
oh you're working overseas routinely and
so what were you making during that time
um anywhere between about 60 to 75 000.
okay and have you do do you have an
emergency fund in place
yes how much do you have in an emergency
fund
um approximately 30. okay
and what other debts do you have i have
zero jobs
zero debt it's fantastic
i do have a roth ira with approximately
80 000
as well okay so in looking at this you
have done a great job
of saving yeah um and and then looking
at it i do want to get you connected to
one of our smart vester pros
to be able to look so you can start to
earmark some of this money
that's over the offshore account uh
beginning to look at it and
calling it retirement yeah um i i think
you know
it is going to be a little tougher right
now to try to qualify
but you don't have any other debt and
you are making 40 000 so if your income
has been stable
i would call around begin to talk to
these
banks and lending companies because your
asset position is strong
now it's just a matter of okay how much
of that in looking at those accounts are
you going to use for a down payment
because a good down payment would put
you in position uh to really be able to
qualify
so that's what i do i begin to kind of
think it through
sit down with the smart investor pro but
have a time frame on
when are you looking to buy right and so
that way you can understand you're not
going to be renting forever you're going
to have an opportunity
to be able to grow forward it's just
going to you're going to need a plan now
from a practical perspective hogan this
is your space this is where you're the
expert at
um i would say that out of hundred
thousand i'm gonna air mark five hundred
thousand for my retirement
take a hundred thousand to put down on
the two hundred some thousand dollar
home
that means that leaves me with a hundred
and twenty five thirty thousand on the
mortgage
she can't afford that forty thousand
dollars yes she could
and and and looking at that and putting
that on a 15-year fix yes she's going to
be fine
matter of fact she might she might be
paying exactly what she's paying in rent
absolutely you know so that's an option
for you michelle
uh again think it through begin to have
some guidelines
uh get all your statements together of
your different accounts
uh you could do a zoom meeting or skype
meeting with one of our smart vester
pros
go to ramseysolutions.com uh it'll get
you connected and then what you can do
is start to see this picture for
yourself
and then you stay in control of the time
frame uh but i love your saving spirit
young lady
you're not scared to work and you also
save which is phenomenal
it's putting you way ahead of the game
at 49 years young
and we all know the income has the
opportunity to be able to go up
uh just as things open up more yes all
right speaking of this
a lot of people are stressed out about
retirement accounts right now in this
year
this past year was crazy uh maybe you're
close to retiring and now you're
wondering
do i work a couple of more years to try
to make up for the difference
uh or maybe you weren't investing in the
right things and you're thinking okay
it's time for me to make some changes
and i need to get a little bit more
aggressive or maybe you pulled money out
and you're looking back on it going i
wish i should i didn't do that
what can i do about it bottom line if
you're in one of these situations i want
you to know you don't have to face this
pain alone
working with an investment professional
is crucial and our smart investor pros
aren't scared
they've seen stuff and they're not there
to judge you they're there to help you
so go to daveramsey.com smart bester or
do this my friends
text the word invest to 33789
again the word invest to 33789
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
chris hogan and host along with me this
hour is anthony o'neil
and we are very excited to be with you
uh if you've not had a chance to check
out the website i want you to go to
daveramsey.com
uh we have a lot of openings uh and
talking about that i was just talking
about this more in the break in the
lobby with someone
and so you've got a great opportunity to
be able to find
a position that you're passionate about
and get plugged in go to
ramseysolutions.com and check out the
openings that are out there
uh we'd love to have you join the team
all right we're getting back to the
phones if you're out there and you've
got a question
this is the day to pick up the phone and
let's talk about it uh the number to
call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
again that's eight eight eight
eight two five five two two five we'd
love to hear from you all right we're
gonna go to georgia
uh looks like we got sarah on the line
sarah how are you
i'm good guys how are you oh we're
focused and not finished what's on your
mind today
well we we got a little crisis going on
so hopefully you guys can help
um what happened my husband and i
we are military so we're finally home
and we brought a home
va loan of course and we didn't know
about you guys so
don't bite my head off we didn't know
about you guys until
january so we bought the house in
december okay
so we started the we're doing babysitter
run because we're doing financial
peace university so we're doing
everything and we're in baby step
two okay however the crisis
is that has to be bought the basement
flooded
and it's been flooding
in february beginning in february
and we've had three plumbers come in and
they're telling us
we need to one they're saying that the
sellers probably did the work themselves
and did not do it correctly
all three of them are saying that and
also
they're um telling us the work is going
to cost about
between 10 to 15 000 to get it sick
okay so hold on a second so it's 10 to
15 to get it fixed
have you reached out to your realtor yes
it did and she looked at it and saw
there's a bathroom that was
remodeled and so there was no planet
food and then
got us in contact with a lawyer trying
to
figure out what to do with the lawyers
yesterday
and they're saying that they're gonna
write a letter to the sellers hoping
that they would cover
the damage but if they don't it will
take you one year
because they'll covet there's a
you know a delayed in court oh the court
thinks yeah let me ask you this
did you all get a home inspection done
yes he did and this was not on it at all
like the realtor also double checked
okay well
here here sarah first of all i want to
thank you and your husband for the your
service
in the military i'm grateful for you and
i like that you have been
hyper proactive uh everything that i've
asked you you've got an answer for
you've been moving down the path
now the main thing is we got to get this
fixed right
right so what's true all's income
we bring him uh eight thousand dollars a
month
okay it came up and what else do you owe
on outside of this home
okay um i have it right here my
loan rental plus um i have
a government credit card 2400
in my car which is 36 000.
i'm sorry you faded out on me on that
how much is this car
36 okay you didn't fade out i was just
making you say it one more time
how what's what's the payment on this
thing
um 800 how much is the payment on your
mortgage about
15 45.
do you see a problem there sarah yeah
all right so guess what one of the first
things you all can do to help you with
this
finding this money to fix this basement
is this vehicle what kind of car
is it it's a tell you that
okay all right i want you to go out
there and tell it to ride
all right ride on off into the sunset
it's time to sell this thing
it's time to kick it to the curb you're
going to free up 800
a month in your budget right and so
this is that mindset listen to me i love
that you guys are in ramsey plus
and how hey i want to get your thoughts
on this but i love that y'all in ramsey
plus i love that you know your numbers
you're proactive and what i would say is
right now you're on the cusp of being
able to make a change
but one of the sacrifices i would make
is getting this vehicle sold
go to kellybluebook.com find out the
value call
up the lender get a 30 day payoff so you
know what it would take to get it out of
your life
you guys go get a thousand or two
thousand dollar car you're gonna free up
eight hundred dollars to fix this water
problem yeah
sarah i'm curious do you have any uh
savings right now
we have um about
5 000. about 5 000 in savings okay
okay um here's my suggestion from i
agree with hogan we got to get that car
but right now
we we need to really figure out this
whole flooding thing because that can
cause some more issues
and so while you're going through the
process with your attorney i will reach
out to maybe one more
uh one more plumber one more person to
see what they can do
and try and figure out will someone work
with you
okay while you're talking to your
attorney why are you looking to get out
of this car
uh to create some free some extra income
there but even if you sell your car
today
it's only x it's an extra eight hundred
dollars but right now
um which you need to get rid of that car
so you can get on your journey but how
do we get this flooding fixed
so that way we don't have mildew issues
we have to worry about a lot of a lot of
other issues so i would you got five
thousand
sit on that five thousand and moving
forward i want you to pause
paying your debt okay i want you to
pause paying your debt
i want you to put that on top of this
money that's gonna all go towards
fixing this water leak all right because
this is a this is a true emergency
that could impact the family and cause
more issues
you mean paul's paying extra on yeah
paul's paying extra on the day i want
you to pause i don't want your paws
paying your bills
but i want you to pause paying extra so
pause babysit number two
but then figure out okay talk to winner
extra person and then ask all three of
them hey listen
we got seven thousand dollars what can
we do to
uh fix this issue we can give you seven
thousand dollars cash
right now can y'all come down can you
help us
what can we do but do what hogan says
you guys
a kid i mean 800 car note that is
uh 50 more than 50
of your mortgage payment that is
ridiculous
but you're right ao the water's got to
get drained out yeah we got to turn off
the water down there or
fix like you said get seven thousand
dollars worth of it done
the good thing is is you all are making
8 000 a month yeah so
you know you all paying the mortgage
payment make the minimum payment on the
credit card
paying that car note until you can get
that thing sold
you guys could can get this done in
phases absolutely uh
and get it fixed i agree uh but yes
definitely pursue the legal options on
this because this is uh this is an issue
and uh this is a major dollar repair
that you all are dealing with
uh but don't lose hope uh this is the
thing one of those things that life
happened ao was just talking about his
car issues and i've walked through some
issues and
it's really easy to get so frustrated
and irritated that you lose hope
and you don't want to do that and so
sarah i'm glad you reached out you're
talking about this is on your mind
uh believe me you know you you can end
up giving other people hope
by being honest enough and open enough
to talk about your own situation
uh thank you and i'm glad that you're
plugged into ramsey plus it means you're
connected and getting the right
information now it's the
the execution of of the the process and
trying to get this thing resolved
i agree and that's you know it's
irritating man i tell you when you deal
with a setback
when you are moving forward and trying
to go down the path to the next
destination
and deal with life throwing you a curve
it's frustrating it's so
frustrating hogan and i understand her
pain man
because i'm literally going through it
right now like i didn't ask for this i
didn't want this
but when you that's this is why you got
to get out of debt
have a fully funded emergency fund for
when stuff like this happens
it sucks but you are prepared yeah for
it that's right
and people are dealing with this in all
phases whether it's in your apartment
whether it's in your home
a car repair yes i mean it's always
something popping up
but you know here's what i've learned
when you have an emergency fund
an emergency fee and turns an in an
emergency into just an inconvenience yes
where you just go like this
oh well i mean all right so this is what
i got to do this is what i got to do
right i'm going to deal with this but if
you don't have an emergency fund
it turns it into oh my goodness like
where do i turn what do i do
and then you get panicked then you get
desperate and then that's when stupid
can creep in
right so again get to emergency fund be
clear on what it is you're doing
but be certain of what you're not gonna
do this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
chris hogan and hosting along with me is
anthony o'neil
and we're excited uh you all may not be
aware
but there is a ramsey network yes
we got a ramsey network uh all of us all
the person ramsay personalities here uh
have
shows uh whether it's dr john deloney uh
rachel cruz myself christy wright
uh you know we ken coleman we have a
ramsey network
uh obviously the ramsey show and so
you've got an opportunity to be plugged
into content
that actually will help you change your
life uh anthony o'neil has a show
called the table where he's having real
relevant conversations with people about
life and money and so you have my show
the chris hogan show the christy wright
show
so i want to encourage you out there i
know people like to watch certain shows
and be entertained
whether they're talking about maisel or
yellowstone or whatever else is out
there
but you've got an opportunity to get
some content to help you change your
life
and this is different so we need to be
about business
about making progress about being
intentional and not just having fun
well hold on wait wait wait wait wait
wait they're gonna have fun with my show
bro i said not just having fun oh okay i
was about to say you're gonna have fun
and you're gonna learn something now on
your show they they may not have as much
fun
they're gonna learn a whole lot you know
but they you know i beg to differ
i'm just keeping the one hundred well i
see your show i learned a lot
i had fun on your show you had me on
there we had fun
dude it was one of my best shows i need
to come back yeah bro it was a lot of
fun you haven't had me on yours so i
just want to call that out
i beg to differ when that free degree
launched you were on there
that was a business move man i want a
fun move
but we'll figure out something we'll
figure out some fun moves
ao and i will arm wrestle or something i
don't know we'll figure out what's going
on
who will win that one you sure do deep
down in your little bitty heart you know
who's gonna win that
but here's the deal we want to take your
calls about life and money
uh don't pay any attention to us but we
are here to help you call us the number
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five again that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
want to meet you right where you are and
talk about the things that are on your
mind
and on your heart all right coming up we
got james over in baltimore
land of real seafood james how are you
i'm good how are you doing today oh
we're focused and not finished my friend
i what's your question for us yeah
so like the previous caller i am also
active duty military
um myself is an optometry technician
um currently we make about i'd say
roughly around six grand a month
combined
um and my wife has forty seven thousand
dollars in student loan debt
okay we recently just paid off our
second vehicle i just made a payment
with our tax return that came in um and
i'm just trying to see if i'm taking the
right approach to paying this
student loan debt off currently my wife
solely works to put her entire paycheck
towards the student loans
wow and so i'm just wondering if while
these loans are in forbearance
apparently with the current
situation the pandemic if it's worth um
paying the loans off or building up our
emergency fund because currently have
nothing in savings
pay the loans off man pay the loans off
and i'm gonna tell you why and i try not
to be so aggressive when i hear this
when
i hear people say this but they're in
forbearance this means that they're not
racking up interest right now all right
and so for you
what i'm saying is you want to go in
ahead and take advantage of this like
i'm trying to figure out
how to get all of these student loans
knocked out before the interest is
activated
uh again and so with the way the
government is looking right now
it may be a little bit of time you know
but i'm saying take advantage of this i
get it you want to have a savings
account and we want you to have
a fully funded emergency fund but i want
you to be debt
free before you have a fully funded
emergency fund
because what you're doing is yes you're
going to put more money into the savings
but long term you're going to spend more
money into debt that you didn't
have to do because you was trying to
save money so what i'm saying save
yourself true money
by paying off all these student loans
which is forty seven thousand dollars
thank you so much for your service but i
promise you
uh when you pay these student loans off
uh my brother i promise you
you'll thank yourself down the road now
um now
so yo is he all listening i mean he
ain't the only one hogan who's asking
that question no not at all i mean this
is a question that you get all the time
me and dave get i get on my show well
why why pay
why pay when i don't i don't have to pay
right now well
you do have to pay if you want to save
money
like that's how i look at it i have to
save money
i have to change my future so i have to
pay these student loans off
so i can get my life back and start
focusing on the future
not worrying about my past no you're
absolutely right and james i would tell
you
you know my friend you want to get a
thousand dollars and have that as just
the starter emergency fund yeah and then
that way if something happens car repair
truck repair
whatever you've got money you can reach
and not have to utilize that
but anthony's right you need to attack
this debt with a vengeance
uh and delete it and get out of your
life anthony this brings up something
else
what's that we'll have to go here
because people are having their ears
tickled
out there hearing about loan forgiveness
yeah hearing about how the government is
going to save the day
they're going to roll through on the on
the little horse
with the with the student loan ferry and
they're going to sprinkle dust on
people's student loans and forgive it
yeah you know hogan man
and i'm trying to be sensitive when i
say this because
you know and this is what i study you
know right now i
studies are showing as of today that the
student loan forgiveness program
is not working nearly 85 of the people
are being declined
um i think a higher number came out here
recently today
but the government is talking me and
dave talk about this um earlier this
week
that the government is there there
probably will be something in the future
but
we don't know so for me my thing is
because we can't say
yes or no we're sticking with the no
we're going to take care of our
responsibilities
and if it comes then take advantage of
it
but as of right now past experiences are
showing us
the government will not forgive the
student loans
right well and they're definitely going
to do it to the level that people are
expecting
no like i've heard 10 grand yeah but
here's the thing have you heard this
yeah if they do this they're talking
about a community service component
exactly well i'm paying the 10 grand you
ain't about to make me sir
but how long and what what are you going
to have to do so
my point is is for people out there i'm
with you anthony
i don't want you to have fake hope in a
false plan
right let me say it again i don't want
you to have fake hope and a false plan
i want you to deal with the known right
and so you know you have in the mindset
of you digging your way out of debt
i know the moratorium on student loans
is through now september
yes uh and so you know you not being on
hold because here's my fear ayo
people that have gone without paying it
yep and you already know what happens
with people if you're not on a budget
come on
now all of a sudden in september you're
going to be like you're going to hear
that knock
yes that this payment is now active
again yes yes yes yes yes and here's the
thing hogan
and correct me if you if you disagree i
we're not saying that we we don't have a
problem that we need to fix
but the problem is not forgiven the
problem is stopping it from even
happening
so i think when people hear us like oh
dave and anthony is just don't they're
not no no what we're saying is okay yes
this is a problem
let's fix it but i can't fix the leak if
i don't fix what's causing the leak
okay so i can't stop the water from
dripping if i don't
fix the hole that's inside of it so for
me it's like let's
stop the student loan program or let's
put a cap on it
let's do something because if we forgive
like what they're talking about the ten
thousand dollars would be close to about
uh 600 billion dollars we still have 1.1
trillion dollars in student loan debt
that is still a major crisis
and will we will be back to 1.7 in the
next few years
so what i'm saying is we're going to be
back well let's pause over here
let's go to the front end and fix the
issue so
my kids your kids our great great
grandkids
do not have this issue going into the
future yeah
no i agree i mean it is certainly a
massive issue
and you know financially as you start to
look at it you're impacting 44 million
americans yeah with student loan debt
and you know the thing that i get riled
up about is that you know we got young
people walking into financial aid
offices
signing documents they don't understand
for payments they can't afford
zero can't afford it and so now you
start off life
in the hole and behind so that's why
again that's why you wrote your book
debt-free degree
uh how to destroy your student loan debt
and so if you're out there and you
want to know how do i get this out of my
life i want you to check out anthony's
book
but at the same time staying plugged in
understanding that we're here to help
you
and you're going to battle your way out
of this we're not going to just sit and
wish
right no no no we're going to work and
we're going to battle
and we're going to strive for progress
because that's what people do
when you're focused and not finished
let's go this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone this is the ramsay
show i'm chris hogan
and and this young person over here
beside me is anthony o'neil
uh he he's helping young people all
around the place he's helping people
deal with money
he's helping people attack student loan
debt and i'm helping people too
on the chris hogan show helping people
understand that your retirement
is about you being focused and not
finished uh and you can
come over and check out the show uh you
can find me on youtube
apple podcast google podcast uh we have
a lot of fun over there with the
segments uh with did you know
where i try to stump you and give you
some information we also do a segment
called panicked or pumped
and that's where we talk to people that
are feeling panicked about a certain
situation
or even pumped about a milestone that
they've hit so
got a great opportunity come check it
out uh go to chrishogan360.com
all right anthony and i have had a blast
taking calls and so
kelly is relaxed over there we need to
get her hair on fire
so i'd love for you to call in triple
eight eight two five five two two five
again that's eight eight eight eight two
five 825-5225
we i i need kelly to get frazzled so if
you can call
it i didn't say that you're such a brown
nose
all right listen people want you to call
in let's get these phone lines cracking
and talk to you about your life and your
money
uh next up we've got rachel in little
rock arkansas
rachel how can we help you hi
so i am 19 years old okay
and i moved out of my parents house
officially in september
and i have a full-time job i tried the
college life
and decided i wasn't going to waste
money if i didn't have a plan okay
um so i have no debt my car is paid for
i paid for my car
um i haven't had any type of credit card
um but i'm trying to make a decision of
if i need to
buy a newer car first
for stability's sake okay or if i should
get a house and stuff
renting because my car is 2008.
okay 2008 how many miles are on it
uh 151. 151
what kind of car did you say it was
again rachel
it's a subaru impreza okay gotcha you
have to laugh don't make fun of your car
it can hear you yeah
okay don't you don't want your car to
get upset so be nice
here okay uh rachel how much money do
you have in your bank account right now
um so i have my one thousand dollar
emergency fund and then
um on a separate thing
i have a i think 2500
when you say a separate tax return
for 2500 because i didn't get a stimulus
check when they came out since i lived
in my parents house they're giving me
those as well
so when you say a separate thing are you
talking about a separate bank account or
do you have this invested like one of
those outcomes just want to make sure
it's not
investing one of those little apps that
people are saying we're saving up for so
you got 3 500
saved up what are you making annually
right now
um annually 28 000 before tax
28 000 before tax all right correct
all right so i'm gonna give you
something you may not like okay cool
great so here's the thing here's the
thing you're doing great i want to say
this right now you're 19 years old you
have no debt
uh you got 3 500 in your savings account
uh so let me go
let's talk about the car i think that
you the car is great you have 150
000 miles on it it's a reliable car i'm
gonna tell you
just keep up with the maintenance if you
take care of the car
getting it properly maintained as far as
oil changes tire rotations making your
fluids are good
as long as you stick to that that car
will last you
to about 200 220 000 miles you know
then from there on the flip side i want
you to really start getting don't worry
about a house right now
all right i want you to skip over to
baby step number three and i need you to
set aside three to six months of your
expenses
then while you're doing that i want you
to go connect with our good friend ken
coleman
because we need to get your income up
you're at 28 000
a year right now which is okay i'm i'm
okay with that at your age
but we need to get you up to right
around 50 000
then we can start talking about
purchasing a home
but once you do get your three to six
months of expenses
i don't have a problem just going over
to 3b start saving a little bit
uh but what i really want you to do is
get your your shovel a little bit bigger
and ken coleman if you go to
kencoleman.com
and listen to his content he'll teach
you how to get into that career space
and figure out how to really do that uh
but that's what i really want you to
focus on at 19.
getting your income up getting a fully
funded emergency fund
but i love it i expect to see you in the
house by 22
by 21 22 if you really do these things
over the next two years
but i think you're in a perfect place my
little dream is to have a tiny house so
the house i want would be like
twenty to forty thousand dollars it
wouldn't even wait hold on rachel what
do you mean a tiny house
yeah they're that's popular how big are
they they're tiny
what really they're like
hold on ayo hush what how how many
square feet
like 300. listen man it's popular within
this younger generation 300
and she can pull it it's about my size
i'm living that minimalist life y'all
hey there's nothing wrong with that
listen don't you let the world try to
tell you what you need to do
it's good that you have your own dreams
uh you know
but at the same time i think you move at
the at the speed of cash like anthony
was telling you
and you having that down payment uh is
big here's another thing
this subaru which you need to go out
there and give it a hug and tell it
you're sorry because you was making fun
of it
that might be able to go 200 250 000
more miles
but here's the reality it doesn't have
to be miles that you put on it
you can move at the speed of cash and so
you thinking of side hustles
you being intentional you could come up
with money to replace that car sooner
than later
but don't don't get caught up in it the
car's job is to get you from point a to
point b
it's not to try to impress people and
when people get that
confused that's where they end up
overspending that's where i did my
stupid
uh and so you want to be smart and avoid
car payments absolutely like the plague
uh it's that important thank you for
your call
i love it you know what hogan i want to
say this on the show i want to learn
more about this mini house so if you're
listening right now
um i want you to dm me at anthony o'neil
go to anthony news instagram and if
you're living in a mini house and you're
a millennial
i'm going to bring you onto my and i
want to talk about this i want to know i
want to know i want to learn more about
it i want to come let me come on there
with you yeah let's do it because
because i resell this is it like can you
do you just pick it up no bro it's
smaller than
this and i'm like okay i purchase house
to resell right so i want to learn more
about it so if you have one
no don't don't hit me up if you thinking
about one i want to know if you have one
hit me up on my dm i'm gonna bring you
on to the show and hold on i'm gonna
make sure you on the show too let's talk
about it because if it's 300 square feet
you can't get all your shoes in there
i'm going to tell you right now
because i know i can't get mine in there
so but yeah i'd love to know more about
it i don't know if anybody that's living
in one
and i've got a couple of friends that
work at hgtv and they do some stuff so
we need to get them
all right that's what dmao tell them
your tell them your dm
how'd they do it go to instagram just
hit me up anthony o'neil
okay and you'll see my information there
dm me uh and i promise you we're gonna
make this into a show
yeah we're gonna find out more we're not
gonna go crazy but we want to learn yeah
i mean we may have to go out and and go
to one of these oh bro let's do
that hogan and ale on the road
yes we are going to check out this tiny
house situation
and we're going to find out how they
really work you imagine you walking into
what okay well we have to get that on
camera this is going to be fun what if
we spent the night in water
oh no i ain't doing that bro that's
exactly what we're gonna do we're gonna
do an overnight camping trip i love this
all right listen to me if you're out
there see we're willing to talk about
whatever you want to talk about
you just gotta call us the number to
call is triple eight eight two five
five two two five again that's eight
eight eight eight two five
five two two five don't forget dmao if
you're out there and you have
one of these little tiny houses going on
you can kind of tell us what it's all
about
uh i've been talking to people uh time
and time again
and they oh we're going to do the the
the blinds.com question of the day real
quick blinds.com 100 satisfaction
guaranteed means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more
use promo code ramsay today's question
comes from luke in colorado my wife and
i are currently paying off her student
loans
a wealthy family member of ours offered
to pay off the loans for
us and have us pay them back interest
fee we started off with 124 thousand
dollars and are down to
34 000 in just under 18 months should we
take the loan from them
even though we are not currently paying
interest on our loans as is
and should we continue to pay off this
debt as fast as possible
uh i'm gonna say pretty much hey you
guys do it on your own yeah paid this
thing off you've already chopped it down
from 124 to 34.
you don't need anybody to try to save
the day now you've got this thing yeah
so keep throwing money at that debt
keep chopping it down get it out of your
life when you get out of debt
you give yourself a raise come on now
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the vala car
rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money
i'm chris hogan and hosting along with
me this hour is anthony o'neil
and i can't tell you how excited we are
to spend the next hour with you
talking about your life and your money
now the key is is you got to pick up the
telephone
i mean ao and i we can't just hunt you
down so call us
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five
again that's eight eight eight eight two
five five two two five
we'd love to be able to hear from you
you can also find us on social media
at ramsay's show uh all right ao you
ready for some phone calls
you know i am all right i am as well so
guess where we get to go we're going to
kansas city oh
we get a chance to talk to gene gene how
are you
i am good how are you today oh we're
focused and not finished what's on your
mind
um i just have a question we are
praise the lord finally in baby step
seven all right and we
are we are piling up cash um because
we'd like to
buy some rentals um hopefully that's
something that
you know we can still have an income
after
um we retire so here's my question we
have been piling up cash
and mike i don't know which way to turn
now
should we go ahead and pull the trigger
and buy a rental
or should we use some of this cash
that's piled up
to convert some iras into roth ira
okay now gene tell me what's this pile
of cash how big is it
well it's not that big yet it's about
um sixty thousand dollars okay
and about how much do you all have what
how much do you have in 401ks right now
well all together um with our roth and
arena
are it's about 6.50 um so
the um non-roth is about
three 325. okay all right
and you guys you said you're on baby
step seven correct
yes sir okay so you paid off your home
already correct
yes all right so what type of rental
property are you thinking about buying
um just a single family home okay and
about how much
i would start with a smaller one and
then you know as we
build a portfolio excuse me portfolio
and get nicer ones so you know
probably probably around a
because where we live i can probably get
a decent rental
for about 75. okay
so about 75 000. and so right now as you
look at it uh
what kind of income do you all have
right now each month
100 oh each month i'm sorry uh we make
120
000 a year what we bring home after
taxes is probably about
um 5 000. okay all right
so in looking at this are you and your
husband both excited about rental
property
are you all just looking for income
uh basically just looking for income
because um
yeah we both have a little way we're a
little way out from
retirement but i understand and i asked
that question
i really appreciate you answering it how
you did because
you get some people that are very
excited and passionate about
real estate and they want to have some
real estate
but you were clear for you it's about no
we're just looking for the income
so i in this situation and i want you to
sit down with the smart investor pro
as well as a tax elp so you can run the
numbers but i would say you guys would
be best served
starting to convert some of the old iras
and go ahead and pay in the taxes on it
so now this money is shifting and it's
going to become tax-free
growth for you moving forward yeah
right okay and so again running the
numbers now this doesn't mean that you
all can't eventually buy some rental
property
right but i want you to do only do it
when you're passionate
and here's the other thing only do real
real estate with cash
so good yeah i i don't i want you to pay
outright cash for it
like none of this going back into loans
no more going back into debt y'all been
there done that got the t-shirt
flip-flops and the sun visor
right there's no reason to go back no
more yeah no no
and so you all when you're passionate
about it then go that route
if you're not real estate is too
expensive ao to be dabbling in
hey you teaching good hogan i love
everything you just said brother
that was good yeah no i'm serious it's
just we got to slow down because when
you own a property
guess what you get to repair it all the
stuff
leak toilet issue whatever it is you get
to do it
and ao you know you're not good with
tools
i know i ain't either if he goes beyond
a screwdriver i ain't worth a penny
like don't give me no pliers i don't
even know what i'm supposed to do with
them things okay
but but when you own it outright yeah
you get to fix it
and so uh you know you want to be smart
and you got too many people anthony that
are running off and
you know taking out loans for rental
properties and man oh man if you get a
tenant that doesn't pay you got a
problem
got a huge problem and a lot of people
found that out last year brother
yeah i mean it's a it can be a big issue
so
be cautious um gene and thank you for
calling in again
go to daveramsey.com and you can click
on the smartvestor pro
and you've got an opportunity just kind
of run the numbers and look at this
uh but i like the idea of you all
spending some of that money converting
it's not impacting your emergency fund
and it's really going to set you up for
the future
speaking of investing listen to me you
know we got a lot of people that were
stressed because they didn't have their
money in place
or didn't feel like they had the right
kind of guidance financially
uh a lot of people were working side
hustles last year and having extra
income
or maybe you pulled money out of your
401k uh they said
close to 62 million people pulled money
which breaks my heart because you can
you can undo many years of deposits and
that compound growth that's happening
but again what's done is done but for
you to be able to work with a
conscientious pro
somebody that's not there to judge you
someone that literally wants to sit down
with you and understand where you are
and more importantly where it is you
want to go see that's where the smart
investor pros are different
they're not there to judge you they're
not there to sell you stuff
they're there to help you get to where
you want to go they want to help you
reach your destination
so here's the deal you don't have to run
around looking for the right people
we have found them for you yes you can
go to dave ramsey.com
smart vester we have found professionals
that are going to guide you the right
way
or you can go to chrishogan360.com click
on the dream team
and you can start to build the dream
team you need tax professional
insurance professional real estate
professional as well as a smart investor
pro
smart people don't do it alone you get
the right guidance so here's what you do
text the word invest to 33789
again text the word invest to 33789
and you can find a pro in your area
today and i'm going to tell you ao when
you get the right people on your side
it's a game changer man it's a huge game
changer you know hogan
and here's one of the things i was
telling dave earlier this week man it's
you know i'm looking to build like the
ultimate dream home by when i turned 40
right
so when i told that to my financial
advisor my smartbester pro
it was like hey instead of putting that
money in a savings account you should
just open up your mutual fund because i
started this
you know years ago he was like so you
can get a little bit more interest not
gonna be a lot
but it'd be a little bit more and it's a
great place and they educated me
on that and i was like yo thank you for
educating me giving me the wisdom and
the guidance
on this journey and that's what you want
your financial advisors to do
to not just tell you what to do but
educate you on why you're doing
it that's a strong smart vester pro no
you're absolutely right and getting the
right guidance man i tell you it can
make a game-changing difference
all right people stay tuned don't go
away we're coming right back
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits secure your future today
visit nationalguard.com ramsey to find
out more
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone i'm chris hogan
and co-hosting along with me this hour
is anthony o'neil and i can't tell you
where how much fun we're having
uh and we appreciate all the phone lines
blowing up thank you for calling in
if you've got a question about your life
or your money or a financial situation
uh maybe you're dealing with something
with your parents or trying to help them
or maybe you've got a question you've
always wondered about
uh should you keep the credit card uh is
it time for you to buy a home or how do
you deal with the student loan situation
what i want you to do is pick up the
phone let's talk about it uh call us
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
again that's 888-825-5225 we'd love to
be able to hear
from you and what's on your mind all
right so we're gonna go to the phone
lines and i got adam on the line
uh from texas adam how are you
hi i'm doing good how are you all oh
we're doing fantastic buddy
yeah we're looking forward to talking to
you what's on your mind
so i'm uh 23 years old um but i'm trying
to get my finances
corrected now before i get into anything
later
on so i had a question you know i have a
serious girlfriend and you know i'm
looking to get
married you know um soon she doesn't
know that
wait a minute how serious adam how long
have you all been dating like
about a year and a half okay no
and uh uh all right and so
face your face all right about a year
and a half go ahead
yeah about a year and a half and so i
want to buy a ring cash but i have a car
note
uh and i have some money saved already
and i just wanted to know should i
buy the ring first um or
should i like pay off the car i mean i'm
trying to save money for a wedding
i don't have another job offer that
might pay me six thousand dollars more
you know or a pending job that might
have
been making me sick would you call in to
let anthony
and i decide what you get to do
no well the first pressing thing i
should
ask is that what should i do about the
car should i pay the car
buy the ring or what what yeah that's
what i'm saying that's what we want to
weigh in on so
how much money do you have saved up
about six thousand okay dollars just
been saving
all right and how much do you owe on the
car
i owe um about with the payment that i
just paid it's going to be about nine
seven so ninety seven hundred so nine
thousand seven hundred okay and how much
is this car payment
it's about 265 a month okay all right
what kind of car is it
a toyota rav4 okay okay all right and
now tell me this
this is the big question here this is
going to tell me if you've done your
research or not
how much are you anticipating to spend
on this ring
about uh uh one month worth of income so
probably about three thousand dollars
okay all right how much do you make a
year man
i make about forty thousand a dollars a
year base
we get over time that's before taxes
as well and i just started an operation
at night
with some people where i'm also making
about 50 an
hour just doing some accounting stuff on
the side gotcha
and adam best case scenario in your mind
when is the wedding happening
uh well i spoke to her mother and she
wanted us to at least wait until she's
done with her bachelor's so maybe next
year
by june by may well adam
i was thinking about a year engagement
dylan give it adam no disrespect your
mama
she don't mother-in-law don't have the
right to tell you when to get married uh
so i think once you propose
you're gonna talk to your uh you're
gonna talk to your fiance
and y'all two will come up with that
date and it may be after she graduates
which i think
is possibly a good idea um but uh
sure yeah i thought i just wanted to be
considerate
no i agree i mean hey i think
it was i think it was i think it was a
smart play for you to be considerate
in that and it's okay for the
mother-in-law to have an opinion
come on man an opinion it's not a vote
yeah y'all got the vote right so you got
the opinion but i'm going to tell you
this
adam i i like the idea of you
attacking the car and getting this thing
paid off
now i say that again this is
this is one of those you looking at it
uh and figuring out you seem very
intentional uh could you buy the ring
and propose and still attack and pay off
the car yes you could
yeah but i'm not sitting on the fence ao
is
waffling over here yeah what are you
gonna do i mean i'm not saying i
completely disagree you know what i'm
saying you know
i'm just saying i kind of like the fat
bruh of maybe you getting a
2500 ring two thousand dollar ring right
you don't have to stretch it at 3 000
because it sounds like you listen to our
stuff and we say about a month to two
months of your salary
so i'm saying you can find a good
quality ring for about two thousand
dollars
um and then i will leave you with four
thousand dollars to put down towards
your car
and then i would attack your car while
you're starting to also um
think about once you figure out when you
are getting married so
i love the fact of you paying off the
car but what i do not want to tell you
to do is prolong
love yeah because that's the debt will
be there but you i don't want you to
miss
out on something amazing and i say that
because of a life experience that i've
been through
um you know i prolonged it and i and i
missed out because i want to have my
money right i want to be
this and that and this and that and she
walked away because she's like if you
love your debt more than you love me
then we have an issue and i was like i
don't i was trying to get rid of it she
said but we could have did that together
so what i'm saying is you know i agree
with hogan i want you to attack the car
but i also want to make sure you don't
miss out on the love of your life in
that process no that's a good point and
and we never tell people that you're
going to let a financial decision
yeah uh determine your relationship or
you starting or adding to your family
yeah
uh so you know that that's nothing adam
we would ever tell you to do
yeah but you know like i said you have
the opportunity to be able to buy the
ring yeah
propose and still be determined and
intentional and attacking the debt
the main thing i would tell you guys is
to be very
hyper intentional with this wedding yes
like this is the financial thing that
can get out of control
because unfortunately people end up
trying to have the wedding for
all of the family meaning you're trying
to throw a party for both sides of the
family
and everybody's got opinions it's like
yesterdays everybody has those too
but not everybody gets an opinion on
this you and your fiance
will get to determine what's going on uh
with the wedding and and the kind of
ceremony you want to have no joking
you said it right man i thank you for
saying that because weddings man
the average wedding right now is in
between 20 and 25 000
unbelievable and even with our income
what we make i'm not spending 25 000
on my wedding i'm gonna tell you that
right now my wife listening in the
future don't even ask me
because i ain't doing it oh are you
gonna you're just gonna go there i'm
gonna go there
okay that's ridiculous well 25 000 so
someone else
can come eat my food to celebrate me
no well the main thing to remember is
spending that kind of money this is one
day
you got the rest of the life ahead of
you yeah and so be smart and i say this
because i've heard of people
ao i did coaching years ago and i worked
with a couple that spent around 55 000
on a wedding and i was ridiculous you
know it was absurd
and so it was all a matter of trying to
do things for other people
and what we have to do is be really
really smart all right i want to take a
social question for a.o
uh uh presley asks i ended up with a
degree with no market value
would it be a good second option to
bounce back
meaning do they go back to school and
get a different degree no i'm saying i'm
gonna say well i can't say yes or no
what i'm gonna say is connect with ken
coleman figure out what is your sweet
spot and then what are the requirements
to land your job yeah so if you know
your job let's say for example you want
to be a
barber uh have your own barbershop well
that doesn't require
you know a four-year degree but there
are requirements to get there
i think the main thing people have to do
is identify
what do they want to do i agree what are
they strongest
and then figure out what what's the
direction i need to take
to go there yeah don't don't just go to
school just for something to do
right like go to work yeah like go to
work and get some money and then you can
go to school at night at a community
college
uh it's going to be a whole lot cheaper
while you knock out the prerequisites
while you're figuring out what it is you
want to do yeah but you know don't
don't make being you know a full-time
edge in education
being your full-time experience when
that's not going to pay you you're
paying for it
yeah you're talking good yeah it's just
you know so i agree
ken can help you yes uh over there help
you to dig in and drill into this and
understand
and there's a good place to go when
you're confused and it's called work
go to work pile up money that way you
can attack debt
or avoid debt moving forward stay tuned
everybody we're coming right back
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone this is the ramsey
show i'm chris hogan and hosting along
with me this hour is anthony o'neil
uh we want you to know that we want to
talk to you
so if you're out there and you have a
question pick that phone up give us a
call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five again that's 888-825-5225
and i also want to remind you if you've
been out there and you've been
intentional
and you've been working this process and
you get yourself to debt-free status
we want to know you've got an
opportunity you can connect with kelly
you can come in and do your debt free
scream on the stage
i just met some folks out in the lobby
allure earlier
that chopped down and and and evicted
that out of their lives gave himself a
raise you should have seen the smile on
the face
got the happiness and everything going
because it's not an accident when you
make sacrifices
you can make progress and so if you've
done that we want to hear from you
and also if you're on that journey i
want to remind you
listen to these debt-free screams listen
to this visceral moment where people
are claiming back their financial lives
and that will keep you motivated keep
you incentivized to stay
on the journey we can all fall off the
wagon
we can all get tired or frustrated or
fed up or have some life happen
it doesn't mean you can't try again you
just gotta climb back up on that wagon
and start moving forward all right we're
gonna get back to the phones we got
steve on the line
uh steve what's your question for
anthony and i
hi steve thanks for taking my call yes
sir thank you
i've got i've got a an inheritance
coming
by approximately 170 000.
and i want to know if i should apply
that to my mortgage
or should i invest that no hail what do
you think
man let's ask some follow-up questions
here see uh excluding your mortgage
do you have any other debt i do not
okay what's in your savings account
right now
about twenty thousand okay you got 20k
in the savings
how much are you investing right now uh
i have total invested right now between
uh 401ks 457s stuff like that probably
about 285 000.
285k okay what are you making a year
i make about 100 okay let me quit 100.
combined income
uh is about 140. okay and how much is
your mortgage
it is one it's the the remaining is 234
000. okay 234 thousand dollars
sounds like you're already putting the
15 percent into your uh your investments
you already have a fully funded
emergency fund
man for me if i'm in your shoes say it
again
all right you're correct okay cool so
for me i'm taking that 170 and i'm
putting it towards my house
dumping it towards the house all of it
single day so i so i keep getting
i'm asking all kinds of different i'm
asking everybody so if i can make
if i can make 12 or you know 10 or 12
in the stock market and the interest
rate on my mortgage mortgages
2.8 isn't that counterintuitive
uh we me and hogan both laughing go
ahead hogan
what uh um in looking at this steve
what we're talking about um and and i i
don't want you to
we can go down the r the rate and talk
about the the rate of return and things
of nature but i want to hit you with one
word
that is the word that will really be the
difference in that equation
and that word is risk and when you owe
on a mortgage
you have debt and debt brings risk and
so
what what i like is the mindset of you
throwing the 170 toward this mortgage
balance
and you staring down at your statement
and now only owing 64
000 on your home how much is your
mortgage payment each month
uh 1800 so 1800 so you looking at this
and the the reality is is by 2022
you could own your home outright right
and now you don't have 1800 a month
leaving you now you could be investing
an extra 1800 a month and what would
that bring you
you see it's all a matter of perspective
now another thing that you could do
as you look at this is you could put a
large majority of this toward the home
right ao i call this the pie graph
approach i used to do this when i'm
working with entertainers and pro
athletes
if they were getting a big bonus or a
big thing coming in i would essentially
say okay let's divvy this up like a pie
okay
like how much of this are we going to
invest how much of it are we going to
apply to
usefulness okay and how much of it are
we going to enjoy
okay so looking at this the enjoyment
factor maybe that's five
grand maybe you're going to take a trip
in honor of that family member that left
you this money
okay or you're gonna buy a new watch or
a necklace to remember them by that's
the enjoyment side
but now let's the use side this is where
i'm either gonna apply it toward debt
okay apply it toward the house college
savings things of that nature
okay and then how do i invest some right
and so
again uh steve you could sit down with
your wife and you guys could look at
that
i think your hold up is man i'm getting
this inheritance and i ain't gonna get
to do nothing with it right if i'm using
it all toward the house right so that
pie graph approach could work
i mean yeah i like that pie i mean it's
a great example i mean five thousand
dollars take a nice vacation with the
family
um you know he can apply something
towards that and invest it but me
i'm i'm investing all of it oh no you're
you're going to use the debt
you're going to use off the house as far
as an investment into my house that's
right
i'm with you now you and i are on other
levels yeah we're we're strange yeah
because we go oh no we know the value of
being gazelle intense
absolutely and so but again having that
mindset
you start to think steve in just about a
year later
yes 1800 didn't leave in you right so
you could use that money toward
renovations you could use that toward
all kinds of things for the future and
it just requires us thinking a little
bit different sure
it really does all right let's stay on
the phone uh oh i get to go to the
mother state
kentucky i got eric on the line eric how
are you
doing well guys how are you oh focus are
not finished what's on your mind buddy
yes a quick question uh my wife is an
occupational therapist she's a
1099 contract employee she works for
company
and she is but she's considered
self-employed when we go to file taxes
right should we be filing quarterly
or as long as we save up uh throughout
the year
can we pay at the end of the tax season
oh okay how much is she making in her
job
uh 35 to 40 000. oh you definitely want
to pay quarterly
yeah yeah okay yeah because the irs
could actually penalize you
all because you're not paying quarterly
and so if you wait and do it annually
you could get hit with a penalty um i
i want you to reach out to one of our
tax eops and clarify
because she's making real money um and
most of the time people like your wife
or or who are realtors
or things of that nature and they're
making you know upwards of 30
40 grand or more the quarterly is going
to be the best way now it's going to
require some structure
right because you got to be disciplined
enough to make sure you're setting aside
the money
but to avoid the penalty you definitely
want to be paying quarterly my friend
so good yeah so um and and it's again
you just you know you set aside 25 to 28
of all the money she has coming in and
you can figure it out you know
all right let's see let's go let's stay
we're doing good jenny how are you
hi sir how can we help you today
i i have a little little dilemma
i don't know which one to pay first if i
have a tax return
of 8 000 should i put it towards my
mortgage which i'm at less than 40
000 or should i put it towards my school
loans
and don't fall off you're dead which i
i'm at 61 000.
i might go wrong school loans yeah
school loans
yeah school loans here's why real quick
because we bout to go to commercial
break
uh your house you're good okay you're
good there
uh your student loans is hitting you
with interest left and right well right
now you're not paying the interest if
they're governor right now
yeah but what i want you to do is go
ahead and get that not down as much as
you can
before you do start paying interest back
on it but so take that eight thousand
dollars take any
extra money you have coming towards it
knock out those student loans
and then go to uh your mortgage
okay all right so regardless of the
balance regardless
yeah yeah jenny and like ao was saying
the house is separate we want to knock
out all consumer debt
yes loans credit cards car loans all of
those things everything except your
mortgage
apparently want that deleted out of your
life then build up a fully funded
emergency fund
then you can start working on the house
so that's the order
and again just you know and also talk to
your tax professional
we got to figure out why your refund is
so high you can get more of that money
each month as opposed to letting the
government have a tax-free loan but i'm
not going to get started on that right
now
because we're going to commercial break
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
chris hogan and hosting along with me
this hour is anthony o'neil
uh we're excited to be with you but i
want to start off and i want to do
today's scripture
is coming from proverbs 9 9. give
instruction to a wise man and he will
be wiser teach a righteous man
and he will increase in learning today's
quote
tell me and i forget teach me and i
remember
involve me and i learned that's from
benjamin franklin
all right we're having a blast hanging
out today taking your calls we have
hit many topics uh and we want to keep
talking to you keep connecting with you
right where you are so we're going back
to the lines and we have jessica on the
line jessica how are you
um i'm okay how are you i'm doing all
right young lady what's on your mind
um the reason i'm calling is because i
am 36 years old
and my husband passed away three weeks
ago
um unexpected oh
jessica it's very awful i'm so sorry
well thank you um we've been following
the dave ramsey steps since about
2018 and so we have no debt and i did
get life insurance
um and it's for 1.15 million dollars
okay um and so
i'm not of course i have like people
giving me financial advice
yeah um but i know because of the steps
that i need to pay my mortgage off
and top up my emergency fund yes ma'am
and but i'm just wondering
beyond that like do i need to keep
contributing to 15
every year for my retirement okay
jessica there are
many steps that uh you're going to be uh
facing yeah uh decisions to make uh
but right now it's all a matter of the
timing of those things
and young lady i'm so glad to hear
that you all were plugged into the plan
and you got life insurance in place
uh what happened to your husband
um well it's pretty crazy but
no they don't know like basically i
found him
collapsed in the bathroom in the morning
and he was fine the day before
okay so there's they did an autopsy but
they still
don't know and they think maybe he had a
heart arrhythmia that's very rare
right i'm so sorry uh do you all have
any children
we have no children okay do you have
family near you
i do okay i'm glad and that support
network is really important
um here's what i say jessica whenever i
bump into somebody and unfortunately i
have
encountered many people going through
different phases of life in my 20 years
of doing this
uh but typically what i advise people to
do is when you have life insurance come
in
i want you to park that money into a
money market account
uh i just want you to park it right over
there it's not a time to try to make
decisions
it's not a time to be moving forward and
just let it sit
there for two to three months uh while
you gather yourself you're going through
so many things
walking through so many trying to make
decisions and dealing with
all these things coming at you you need
a clarity of
mind and a peace of mind as much as
possible while your heart
hurts and so parking that over money
market account
uh like you said you've got a lot of
people coming at you and unfortunately
you've got a lot of sales people coming
at you
and you can also have some people that
have the right heart to guide you
but you want people to come alongside
you and be able to point you in the
right direction
and so yes you do want to keep working
the steps one of the things i would ask
you to also to be really as my
grandmother would say be prayerful and
careful about
is what's the future of this home look
like for you
and i say that because it may not be a
place you want to be
it may be too painful of a reminder for
you and so
putting that home on the market might be
something you consider doing
or you may want to stay there and pay it
off so you're gonna go through and make
some decisions for yourself
uh moving forward but i want those
decisions to be on your terms
i don't want you to feel rushed or
feeling like you have to hurry up and do
something
uh just because you've had the thought
you may want to put get a notebook and
start to jot some things down
some ideas and questions and if you want
kelly will get your information i will
get you connected to one of our
financial coaches
someone that can walk alongside you and
help you kind of begin to make the list
of questions
not do anything just yet but somebody
you can talk to about the thoughts and
ideas you have
so you can begin to kind of make a game
plan for yourself and so i'm going to
take care of the first three meetings
with that financial coach for you
um and just know i'm praying for you i
want you to make sure that you
get connected to a therapist and a
counselor uh you've got some grief that
you're gonna have to walk through
uh and get people around you just don't
isolate
that's what i wanna tell you uh as a
former master isolator
uh when you isolate yourself you're only
with your own thoughts and your own
feelings
and it's so good to have somebody to be
able to bounce that off of
no that's so good man and i'm trying not
to be emotional man because you know two
weeks ago we just lost my cousin
they're dead as well and one of the
things i want america to hear
is life insurance is so important
she was a she was a steward and an avid
listener of me and she
had a very healthy life insurance policy
in place
and it felt so good uh to see my aunt
and my my cousins her siblings to be
able to bury her in peace
not be frustrated with how we're going
to provide for things
i'm hoping to pay for things and to hear
her that
now she can pay off her mortgage she can
mourn
in a joyful way not in a how am i going
to survive way
and i just want to hear america i can't
remember our information on how they get
life insurance checkups and stuff like
that man but this is so
important my cousin was 28 years old
hogan
you don't know what tomorrow promises
but if you have a family if you have
loved ones
just make sure that you do the hard work
today get the life insurance policy make
sure you have a will in place make sure
you have your things in place
so if the lord does call you home at
least your family can celebrate your
transition
and not not not not just be hurt and
don't hear no you're absolutely right
it adds not having life insurance adds
headache and heartache to already a
hurting heart yes
and so you know we say all the time here
at ramsey solutions
life insurance is how you say i love you
to your loved ones yes
and so i want to do a teachable moment
here for a minute we tell people to get
10 to 12 times your income
in term life insurance so that that 10
to 12 times so
if you're making 50 000 a year you're
looking at 600 to 700 000 in term life
insurance
not through your job hear me you're not
going to do that don't check the box for
two times your annual
income in term life insurance no you
want to get life insurance
outside of your job 10 to 12 times
so if you lose or leave that job you
don't lose or leave behind your life
insurance
so it's important to have this in place
if you have people depending on your
income
dependence maybe your parents are sick
and living with you
if you've got somebody depending on you
then life insurance is necessary
however if you are a individual and
you're single
and you've got an emergency fund to take
care of your final expenses
then no life insurance isn't something
you need so it's really important to get
it and a lot of people say hogan i don't
understand it so i'm going to get it
well guess what i'm going to break it
down for you exactly what's going to
happen
in order to get term life insurance
they're going to set an appointment
they're going to come get your height
your weight
they're going to get some fluids blood
and some other urine and all the things
and they're going to send it off to the
lab and in about six to eight weeks
you'll have a policy
full and in effect okay that's the deal
and so but you have to apply for this
you have to be proactive with it and i
don't want people putting it off anymore
don't no don't tell me you got too busy
you can't get too busy to get this in
place
it's really that important come on man
thank you for teaching that yeah and
by the way people don't understand ao if
you get term life insurance of a million
dollars
and someone passes away and they had a
million in coverage a check for a
million dollars is coming yes
in the mail yes and so that's why i was
given her the advice
of parking that money just to collect
yourself
you know what you don't want to do is
try to medicate buying stuff
that stuff won't replace your loved ones
right and when people end up trying to
make money decisions when their heart is
broken
that just leads to more headache and
heartache way more a lot more regret
yes and so i want people to be
intentional with that uh
be really smart you know and uh i tell
you man it's amazing you never know what
people
might be going through you don't man and
here's the thing what you said hogan is
life insurance is your way of telling
your family i
love you and i will miss you and um
man and i'm just trying to get emotional
myself so thank you for teaching it man
oh absolutely well listen i want to
thank all of you all for tuning in to
the show
uh i want to thank producer james childs
associate producer kelly daniel
i want to thank all of you for tuning in
ao thank you for hanging out
thank you has been fun and until next
time stay focused and not
finished you can do this and we're here
to help this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you